all right the eagles
are in first place in the nfc east but
they stink
and i i mean they do
doug peterson you stink the coach that
you stink coach coach peterson of the
eagles was on uh was on wip earlier
today
talking about who's to blame for the
fact that the eagles do indeed currently
stink
i'm pissed off i'm pissed off at myself
i'm pissed off at the way we played
and and it's just it frustrates me it
frustrates me to no end and
you know it's it's
we have too much pride and i have too
much pride these players have too much
pride we work our ass off during the
week
and and
you know it's it's it's it's frustrating
it is frustrating and um
um you know um blame it on me all you
want don't i mean
i'll handle it with the players you can
blame it on me i'm a big guy i can
handle it that's fine um but this is
we're we're still we're self-inflicting
ourselves we are killing ourselves we're
shooting ourselves in the foot all those
cliche little
you know statements is is still showing
up and
and and it's frustrating
let me tell you the sims isms are
catching on self-inflicting ourselves
that is right out of the christopher
david sims lexicon it is spreading
um
peter here's what amazes me about what
happened to the eagles yesterday doug
peterson and andy reed disciple one of
the things we know about andy reid to
give him two weeks to get ready for
somebody far more likely than not he's
not losing the fact that the eagles with
two weeks could not get it together to
beat the giants are you kidding me and i
saw last night on nfl network
there was a
question on a graphic is doug peterson
in trouble and my first thought is how
could he be in trouble he won a super
bowl he's been in the playoffs the last
three years even if they don't win the
division this year it's only one
consecutive season without playoffs how
could he be in trouble
but you know you got a lot of impatient
eagles fans i don't know how impatient
jeffrey lurie the owner of the team will
be
but something's not right
and
even if nothing significant happens
after this year by way of accountability
i think everybody's going to be on the
hot seat next year if they fail to win
the division
and there still is this sense that that
they aren't getting the most out of the
talent that they have
well mike i mean i think
doug peterson can be as frustrated as he
wants to be but he can't play the game
and i think he made a dumb play call
yesterday
in you know with 20 minutes to go
he's behind by four points
why in the world you go for two at that
point is just totally beyond me and i'm
a big fan of going for two more than you
go for one i i've said it a hundred
times but you get to the end of the game
you gotta play
you gotta play in my opinion play calls
smarter
but the one other point
you know carson wentz right now he leads
the nfl
among quarterbacks in interceptions
he leads all nfl quarterbacks in
giveaways
and
his his passer rating is down 30 points
from two years ago
and mike that
you can you can get all huffy and puffy
and and you can have guys in the locker
room say hey we're 100 behind carson
wentz he's playing like crap
i know the offensive line is
really struggling and carson wentz
doesn't have the time that he used to
have but he's not playing well and we
have been saying this the entire year
there's something wrong with carson
wentz period
so let's diagnose that instead of just
continually falling on your sword and
and again i realize you can't come out
publicly if you're doug peterson or
howie roseman or or jeffrey lurie and
say i'm really worried about carson
wentz
but mike
do you think any of those guys truly
is not really worried about carson wentz
they're all worried about him
what happened to the carson wentz of
2017 and 18 because that guy's not
playing right now
my very low tech uninformed opinion on
this is that carson wentz is trying
in any given moment on any given snap to
justify in one throw in one decision in
one play
moving up to get him with the second
pick in 2016 picking him over nick foles
after 2018 and giving him 33 million a
year in early 2019. he's trying to make
them right on all those things on all
those all-in moves at one time he's just
trying to trying too hard peter to do
too much
you know
in the nfl right now if you have a
quarterback you pick very high
you have to give him a very long leash
it's unlike at any other position quite
frankly
um
if if if a left tackle you pick in the
top 10 is getting the quarterback killed
and it lasts for
10 12 16 18 games that guy's gone
he's not gone
as a quarterback if he does that
look at how long
mitchell trubisky had and i guarantee
you one day it's not going to be
you know soon or in the next two or
three years
if matt nagy gets fired by the bears
someday he'll be sitting on his uh is
sitting in his in his rocking chair
you know and wondering
how come the one chance i had
i didn't get it done
and everybody's gonna say to him you
know it was trubisky it was trubisky and
deep down i guarantee you he may not
ever say it publicly but i guarantee you
that's probably what he'll think
and it's painful it's unfortunate
and
you might be a great great football
coach but a lot of times
you are sentenced to play
with the quarterback who either you
drafted or who was drafted before you
and you've got to make it work
and sometimes it doesn't work and all of
a sudden bang you wake up one morning
and you're the offensive coordinator
again in
jacksonville or whatever it is and you
say what happened how did i blow my
chance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports